the other day I was going to get my hair
cut before I said to San Diego the day
before they'd only accept cash
hashtag Lincoln barbers best in the
world all my teen barbers and those do a
brilliant job anyway they'll accept cash
I'm walked out and I had like whatever
to another's cash but in just two bills
so two to two $100 bills I wanta have my
slick scientists kept I'll work it out
$100 bill slipped on out I didn't know I
kept those rang with my headphones and
keep walking some guy comes up to me
just a man and kinda you know you didn't
look like you're ballin you know you
could tell like you know working in
college man you can't you drop this
oh [ __ ] those hundred dollars man I
didn't grab that one that's hundred
dollars here's ya you literally drop the
back dammit you don't lose how the da so
you can keep it man because you find him
and you can keep it step like yeah
that's really cool man and it's good and
I am I did no no no don't really Stora
like yeah no but that's a good that's a
good man and I think most people would
be that way you want my dad when I was
young then would give him some [ __ ] up
to this we don't quit found ourselves on
the back i down here so I got to start
my ethics my dad when I was young I
found $20 you switch when your kid it's
like oh [ __ ] we goin sizzling pops a
Scrooge McDuck rich I found $20 in the
road up the street us my basketball with
my brother
minor it was weird because I was like
eight little [ __ ] gives you a $20 -
found it almost dropped up there don't
put it back not like how we did a street
dog even though I was like in the street
do go put it back because they might
have dude I like it a lesson
I like the Lausanne lesson yeah I
literally know it okay
I went basking like I crumbled on was it
I am I'm a big UFC Fan and I respect all
combat sports and they're my favorite I
think fighters in general purest form
sport it's raw it's real no team no
equipment it's all you and there you
find out what you're about and recently
I started taking up a few months back
now at jujitsu is a matter fo yeah yeah
I mean I grew up wrestling and it's very
different but I got my son into it oh no
and I kind of wanted to learn along with
him yeah and and I really like it how
old is he he's 3 I think so better yeah
- oh jeez
but guess what he's very guy couple
stripes it in he knows how to mount side
control you get so you know it's it's
good to get with their the body
awareness and control and it's a good
martial art to regression when they're
young sure as an innocent planet ISIL on
door cries or something like that like
they actually have fun and when right
right exactly so and I and I'm having
fun to learn it's are you yeah I really
am sorry are you in a gear no G no naggy
anything keypad clacking Agee the whole
deal just got another striker today so I
really like it and it's not if I can go
in today they have a noogie class on
Monday but I want to get a little bit
more fundamentals under me but it's hard
being a wrestler and certain habits and
I'm not used to just being comfortable
in my back yet no I know that's what is
so weird but I'm doing it there if you
did know you usually wrestlers they have
really good base so noogie you're gonna
flourish a little more especially early
on oh good well I think there's a lot of
wrestlers you know back especially back
in day like Randy Couture against Jacare
where you know they're not black belts
because the wrestling foundation right
noogie that can do work against high
level guys ya know it's encouraging to
see a lot of these guys who have great
wrestling backgrounds whether came
Velasquez Cormier all these act or like
you said all the list goes on and on
that are were able to transition be
successful um and a gap so yeah no it's
cool be a big fan you you you you don't
want to go too easy like Jay and I were
timeout shut up Jay jobs in town for the
big ground bake down tonight but um my
buddy Klopas NFL you know first round
pick our first pick in the second round
freak athlete we talked about he was
sparring a little bit Sparta chick
Sparta girls like um she go easy he got
another girl and I was right he's on
wobbly Street of my Junius Comstock bro
and his jaws all [ __ ] up he's seen
stars you gonna hate me for Dennis doing
because I just didn't know man I have my
happen to me it was over a woman she
came in and just she's trying to keep
training really working to she's
fighting an amateur but she I stepped
aside she's with this is it left hand I
thought I was gonna [ __ ] die right I
was like oh that's bad now we'll keep
going anywhere I never works out when
you spar girls like when I was at high
altitude Osbourne and this guy's wife
she was known for going hard and it just
was a lot of people and just the
rotation were to my I need his sweat all
right and we're going and she's gone so
hard like in whites on side like if you
touch Brent we will give you a million
because if you just took me like she's
going so hard right I'm like I don't
know what to do I didn't want you to
hurt to joy go on
I look around no one's watching like I
gotta do something here to calm it down
he's right to the livers you okay oh but
I think I'm gonna sound like geo you ran
into that one huh you know that's kind
of legit had a girl
you know I would imagine got your size
when you sparred guys always runner
that's right [ __ ] that's a Saxton your
friend Elaine mister hey [ __ ] you I got
wet women matter - that's right women
don't go pro protests a little feminist
you were giving her you were gonna where
you get the guy protest somewhere else
[ __ ] nothing is not up in here don't
ever bring that [ __ ] in my opinion don't
hate your kids and go to another gym
place your Lululemon love and ditch
ourselves go to another gym hey I know
you have big gay fantasies but it wasn't
a bunch of guys like guys what are we
doing we worked out with work folks we
shaved our chests we highlighted right
here well I guess nothing else to do but
come and each other how I do wish you
all reforms of the dangers some Zumba um
I know I'm big guys but if you guys hold
me down and have your way with me I'm
gonna be so mad yeah it's one of my
prison-house please no screws yeah I
guess something to do got it if you saw
this here's one drop some bombs in my
mouth yeah you flexible I don't know
about to find out